54 year old maria antonieta santa
Vanya's is on the metro on her way to
historic women's day gathering women
from all over Chile's capital are
already converging by the tens of
thousands like many here Mary antonieta
belongs to a group called la stessa
senior their choreographed chant a
rapist in your path has become a
feminist mantra the world over women of
all ages occupations and economic
standing filled Santiago's largest
Avenue vowing to fight gender inequality
stereotypes and much more your I belong
to a generation of women educated to be
servants of men I'm a teacher in a poor
neighborhood and I see my young female
students suffering sexual abuse from as
early as kindergarten this has to end in
Latin America rape and domestic violence
are widespread from Argentina to
Colombia to Central America women marked
women's day to say enough mothers and
daughters March together I'm proud and
unafraid to be a woman when my mother
was my age she was abused and could not
speak out because it was considered
normal Chilean women are playing a key
role in ongoing social protests that
began last October over inequality and
now they're celebrating what they see as
a major political victory for the first
time in Chile there will be gender
parity to create a new constitution if
of course we were next month's
referendum but the carnival atmosphere
was marred by sporadic clashes with riot
police
ahead of where we are right now we're
not sure what provoked it but it did
send thousands of women fleeing in the
opposite direction of this Avenue
centavos made her affair but now
thousands more as you can see on
returning going back in the direction of
the presidential palace saying they will
not be deterred in front of the palace
some women dragged away the barriers
security forces responded with tear gas
and water cannon while groups of young
men and women hurled stones at them a
day of celebration and confrontation to
be followed by calls for a nationwide
feminist strike all over Chile on Monday
Lucia Newman al Jazeera Santiago